>> Hi, my name is Anthony Bontrager, I'm the President of a
company called 1Cast.
With me is Travis McElfresh, he's our VP of technology.
We founded 1Cast three years ago in an effort to bring
personalized news content to users across the web and into
the mobile space.
Specifically we found that users wanted to have the ability
to find and search for the news that's personally relevant
to them to be able to watch it where and when they are and
that was the reason we founded the company.
>> So, you chose to create this application on the...
[remainder of the question not audible]
>> Well, we chose the Android platform to develop the
application on because it was a very easy system to use.
Android represents, in our opinion, you know, the leading,
you know, I guess, thought leader, if you will, in terms of
taking a mobile OS and distributing it across different
device types for us.
So, for us, you know, as an ecosystem provider for video
content we wanted to be partnered with someone who shared
that same vision and can take OS into different device types
beyond just the mobile space.
>> Great.
Developers really like your... were there any types of
challenges and could you tell us about that?
>> Could you repeat the question?
>> Technical challenges that you've had to overcome.
>> Technical challenges.
Umm, you know, it's actually been quite easy to develop on
the Android App -- platform.
One of the things we particularly like is the ease of
deployment and that's one of the things that we've found in
other platforms to be kind of challenging is by the time you
create your build and you want that out there in front of
your users with the Android platform and marketplace you can
is have it right out there and just very easy.
>> Great.
What's your prospect of the Android development process?
>> Again, it's gotta be the release process.
We -- we have a -- the ability to take our build, put it
right out there in front of our users, and you know, with
little to no headache and get some instant feedback.
If we need to do updates we can do that quite easily.
>> Yeah.
I think the feedback speed very important for us because the
speed at which Android can be released out there and the
feedback that we get back, it allows us to respond very
quickly to our user base needs.
And we've seen very positive feedback as a result of that.
>> What are some of the features that you do on the Android
platform that you can't do [remainder of the question not
audible]
>> Well, I think it goes to my earlier point around the
whole Android ecosystem, being able to take our application
off the mobile platform and in some of the new devices that
many of the hardware manufactures are going to start
releasing here based upon the Android platform.
So, for us, again, as an ecosystem provider and having that
as part of our mission statement, Android stands head and
shoulders above everybody else.
>> All right.
And are there any advice that you'd give to someone who's
interested in developing in Android?
>> Yeah, absoluteally, two come to mind, around testing and
promotion.
Testing on the Android platform because you can get it out
there in the marketplace, it's very easy, you can make our
own builds, post it on your own site, and point to it, and
allow other people through, you know, some of the crowd
source testing or even your friends to just go ahead and
down load and test it.
That's not available on some of the other platforms. And
around promotion.
You know, figure out that little QR little chart thing.
That's very cool.
You allow people to come by with a little scanner on the
Android phones and have an instant link off to your build to
download to try out.
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent. Well, thank you very much and enjoy the rest
of the show.
>> Thank you.